on a passé une journée avec vous et
niasse barda d'une salle de montage
vous parlez d'objets à une brocante dans
le 14ème c'est nicolas le marinier et
mathieu dreujou qui vous ont accompagné
et mon petit ça que j'aime le cinéma
ma petite caméra qui est là moi j'ai mon
petit outil de travail
voila voila c'est vite fait j'enlève le
bouchon j'essaie d'oublier je vous ai je
peux filmer je peux filmer le rend très
gros titres aux branches site est très
photogénique mais j'étais trop pressé
maputo airs patate la femis ans et une
école de cinéma veut faire un stage de
formation
alors là on va leur donner tous les
rushs de d'une séquence la patate
attaque et ils reverront s'ils veulent
faire un look mental tu leur mets tout
on veut tous les mois je peux pas
m'empêcher d'avoir toujours envie de
monter de remonter et j'ai entrepris cet
exercice périlleux
filmé d'une main mon autre maquis de
l'année des patates en forme de coeur
boulot qu'ils sont différents
voyez quelque chose que je regrette
quand même j'aimais bien d'abord
tripotée de la pellicule et j'aime bien
l'odeur de la qualité alors là c'est un
peu comme on dit ce pasteurisé
le journal ils étaient un millier dans
les rues de paris aujourd'hui salarié de
l'ue et de marks and spencer
ils ont manifesté contre les plans
sociaux qui on est dans une société
c'est clair dans beaucoup de pays du
trot et du trop peu et dans une petite
mesure et dans le modeste documentaire
que j'ai fait on assiste à la même chose
c'est-à-dire trop de gâchis
trop de gens qui jettent trop de choses
et de nourriture jetée et de l'autre
côté ceux qui n'ont rien et qui donc se
nourrissent ce meuble s'arrange avec rs
des autres
[Musique]
moi je vais beaucoup dans les brocantes
pas forcément pour acheter pour moi
parce que c'est des belles choses
les gens qui vendent sont des passionnés
c'est ça le problème
alors on veut bien sûr du coup de blues
s était sculptée dans neuf ans que je
cherche chaque fois ci les cartes
postales
la rue didot c'est mignon c'est le droit
j'en ai trouvé des poils chez moi aussi
je les garde en mon jeu haché si vous
les faites y fait en fait c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont encore là
[Musique]
barcelone c'est mon bras
l'occasion
[Musique]